hello everyone I hope you all had a
great weekend now in my previous video I
said that I would show you another game
by the winner of my arena
Vincent retires from Netherlands also
known as opera vase and unleashes and
the first game featuring the main
Guarini variation was one of my choosing
and this is a game he sent me himself
saying that this is his favorite over
the board game now I checked the game
out and the game is quite quite
beautiful it's actually one of the more
violent games I've ever seen and a lot
of the variations that never happened
are are just as great as the game itself
so I'm sure you'll enjoy it so let's see
the game his opponent is Hank Carson
also a chess player from Netherlands
I believe he's rated somewhere around
2100 unfortunately I couldn't find a
photo of him as most of the photos when
I google Hank Carson are from Dutch
websites so I didn't want to use a wrong
one so here's the hoodie guy Vincent has
the white pieces and he opens with
Knight to c3 this is something called
the van gate opening we have Knight to
f6 and now Knight to f3 transposing into
the reti opening d6 we have g3e 5d3
Bishop d7
Bishop to G - now castles castles and c6
b3 Knight B to d7 we have E for h6
Bishop Bishop to b2 rook to e8 and knife
to D - preparing F for we have night -
f8 f for now and Knight to g4 as Y
decided to push f4
there's really no point in pushing h3
this would weaken the King too much so
g4 seems like a nice square for the
knight also there's the immediate threat
Knight to e4 that would fork the Queen
and the rook
so Queen to e2 not allowing the knight
to come to III and now d5 a black
decides to sacrifice the e5 pawn to get
some counter play with Bishop to c5
check so white accepts F captures only
five and Bishop to c5 check King to h1
only move on the move if you don't want
to lose material nice to e3 now
attacking the rook on f1 and here starts
the game he captures on the
five now black can definitely capture
the rook here if black decides to do
this Knight captures on f1 you get rook
captures on f1 and now as you can see
White has a very powerful center the
rook is ideally placed on f1 attacking
that we kept seven pawn and white will
definitely have compensation before for
this exchange sacrifice if black decides
to get rid of the center for example C
capture Sun d5 then comes knife captures
on d5 and after Bishop to e6 there's c4
and you can see that this is quite a
nice structure White has in the center
if black ever eliminates the knight then
seek after sandy five will again form a
nice Center and moves like d4 when the
knight moves d5 are coming so a lot of
compensation for white here
so after this he capped 475 black
decided not to capture the rook he
played C captures on d5 and here we have
Queen to h5 immediately going for that
weak f7 pawn and here black definitely
could play something like Knight
captures rook captures and then Bishop
to e6 to defend the weak f7 pawn but the
white would still have plenty of
compensation which moves like d4 and
what the Knights who are coming into the
game so after this Queen to h5 move
black decided to play Knight to g6 first
and only then will he decide what to do
with the rook but now it's it's now it's
too late
because rook captures on f7 and rook
captures on f7 is not the winning move
by far the position is still very much
equal and very much playable here you
have to capture the rook if you don't
want to I mean your knight is attacked
here this bishop will become very active
eyeing that g7 pawn so you have to grab
it or you're simply worse King captures
and now comes Knight captures on d5 and
here it's very interesting what can
black do here if you play something like
Knight capture some d5 then you get the
immediate rook to f1 check and you have
to move the King King g8 and now after
Queen captures it's a much better
position for white moves like e6000
paint queen will be harassing the g7
pawn so it's an excellent position for
white so after this night capture some
beef
move black decided to play something
else he played Bishop to g4 and it seems
the White Queen is trapped so unless the
white wants the part with his queen he
has to give up more material to continue
this attack here Vincent played rook to
f1 check and now black has to make a
choice do you grab the rook and allow
Queen captures Bishop on g4 because the
knight and e3 is also protecting the
bishop on g4 or do we move the king and
allow Queen captures on g6 in the game
Knight captures on f1 was played but
let's see just what happens if King to
g8 is played as this is quite amazing if
King to g8 allowing Queen captures and
g6 and now black is simply lost now you
have to play something let's say knife
captures on f1 as that's a pretty strong
rook and I have one but now comes knife
to e4 and whites attack is unstoppable
you can't capture the night because
Knight to f6 with Czech will pick up the
Queen opening up a discovered attack
from the bishop to the Queen and d5 so
nice to e3 you don't want to lose more
material but now comes six threatening
Queen captures on g7 checkmate rook to
e7 blocking and now comes Knight d2 f6
check if you go King to h8 you get Queen
- h7 this will be checkmate so King to
f8 but now comes Knight - h7 check only
move is came to g8 and now comes Knight
to f6 check only move now is King to h7
and now comes Knight to f8 and now you
can see that both Knights are covering
the h7 Square Queen to h7 is a terrible
threat of checkmate but here black plays
Queen to Bishop to f5 and he traps the
Queen so that's very unfortunate
although the Queen can come to h5 you
don't really have to here you can simply
play Queen captures on f5 and black is
doomed
there's still the threat of queen h7
checkmate and if you capture the Queen
you get Knight to g6 and this is
checkmate the Knights are covered
covering all the squares around the
black King so this is just one of the
variations that would happen after this
rook to f1 check if you decided to play
King to g8 in the game Knight captures
on f1 was played and now Queen captures
on g4 here
black black saw that there were simply
too many threats he decided to go for
Queen to g5 offering to exchange Queens
also attacking the knight on d2 here
white played Queen to d7 check and again
you have to decide what to do here
your knight is still attacked on f1 so
if you block with the bishop for example
Bishop to e7 White will simply grab the
night if you play King to g8 white
simply grabs the night and black decided
to defend with tempo so he played rook
to e7 attacking the Queen now comes
Knight captures on e7 and now if you if
you captured the night you're still
gonna lose the knight on f1 so first he
decided to the tryout atactic Knight
captures and g3 would check you can see
that the Bishop on c5 is covering the G
1 square so the knight has to be
captured H captures on jittery and now
Queen to h5 check again this bishop is
nicely covering the G 1 square so only
move for white is Bishop to h3 or Queen
to h3 white decides to go for Bishop to
h3 the Queen is guarding the bishop on
h3 Queen to d1 check we have night 2 f1
the night is now defended by the bishop
going to have three check King to h2 and
now Queen to f2 check Bishop the g2
blocking and now Knight captures on b7
and here white has to proceed very
carefully as black still has a lot of
pieces and the queen is very close to
the white king so first d4 blocking the
bishops battery with the Queen to g1
Bishop Queen captures and c2 first now
if you capture the Bishop on c5 you lose
the bishop on b2 so first East six King
to f8 and now comes Queen capture some
b7 if you capture the bishop now you get
Queen captures rook with check and the
point is covering the f7 square so
you'll have to lose a lot of material if
you allow this rook to d8 and now comes
Queen to f3 check King comes to g8 and
now Queen to f7 check King to h8 and
only now D captures on c5 threatening
checkmate on g7 as the bishop is eyeing
the g7 pawn queen capture sambito and
now Queen captures on E
seven and after all is said and done
White has a bishop and the night against
the rook but the e6 pawn is so far
advanced that this is simply too much
for black rook to defy was played going
for ideas like rook to h5 check so Queen
to e8 check King to h7 and now Queen to
f7 guarding the h5 Square and also
allowing this pawn to go up the board
Queen to e2 we have a seven up and not
rook to h5 check you can't capture the
rook with ideas of promoting because if
Queen captures Queen captures then the
Queen will be guarding the square of the
promotion King to g1 now comes rook to
e5 attacking d7 point twice and now
comes Queen to f3 white is willing to
exchange Queens and give up these seven
pawn because the knight and Bishop will
simply be much better than the rook
Queen to b5 and now King to h2 not
allowing the c5 bone to be captured with
check here black capture the pawn and
now comes the finishing blow
Queen to e4 check offering his queen and
if black would accept this Rose captures
on e4 then Bishop captures on e4 would
check g6 so it's a defending or you can
move move the King but then the pawn is
promoted with check and now the Queen
comes into the game and it's all over
white is up two pieces and the black
doesn't really have any tricks here to
try out there are no perpetual so this
would be simply losing so after Queen 24
check g6 was played but now simply a e8
promoting to a queen and which two
Queens on the board it's all over for
black black tried a couple more checks
Rock h5 check bush blocks Queen f2 check
now Queen blocks and it's all over
white defended and this there is no
point in continuing this with two queens
on the board who had the Queen b7 a
threat of checkmate so in this position
black resigned the game so a wonderful
game by the winner of my arena unleashes
vincent precise opera vision III know
some of you said that I'm pronouncing
his name incorrectly but I don't really
know how to
Dutch names so I tested it on Google
Translate that's how Google Translate
you know pronounces his name so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
enjoyed it immensely as it's you know
features a lot of interesting variations
and a lot of great moves I would like to
thank Doug was rife at the old rivers
and Tara's car pick for a contribution
to my channel thank a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here I think all
for watching and I will see you soon
probably going back to some old classics
from the 1959 candidates tournament and
you know don't feel you know feel free
to to comment on mr. hoodie guy in the
comments to show your support as he
loses a lot of games you know for our
entertainment to love so many important
games throughout history just you know
so we had so we would have some nice
games to watch so thank you all and I
will see you soon